welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you spent
last year watching The Watchmen then
chances are you have a lot of questions
about the show's ending throughout this
video we're going to be going over the
agonizing cliffhanger and discussing all
of the evidence to support why Angela
did walk on water
ivory watched the show from beginning to
end and is actually a couple of tidbits
that indicate exactly what happened
after the show cut to black for the last
time so we're gonna be breaking down the
big signifiers and why it all points to
one certain thing this is obviously
gonna be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen the show and the title and
thumbnail of the video didn't ruin it
for you then I highly suggest that he
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for click in
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of why Angela did walk on
water
okay so HBO's Watchmen send it around
Angela a bar the grand daughter of
hooded justice we learned that she met
dr. Manhattan when she was younger and
that she'd been living with the
character in secret in Tulsa for a
decade
this was unbeknownst to everyone except
Angela and a grandfather even Cal the
docs new identity was unaware of what
was really going on and it led to a
gripping shell that had viewers on the
edge of their seats throughout after an
event known as the white night in which
a group of white supremacists set out to
murder policemen across the city they
discovered that Manhattan had been
secretly walking amongst them led by
Senator Joe King jr. they set out to
capture the character and steal his
powers thus enabling them to rule the
world
combating them was lady Tru who also
wished to set man-hands powers and after
she defeated the cavalry she seemed to
be able to harness his abilities which
seemingly killed him in the process true
look like she was finally going to
possess the abilities of God however at
the last second she was killed by a
father
Ozymandias Angela returned home with a
kids and grandfather will who was now
part of the family she cleaned the mess
up that had been left by Cal after his
transition and discovered a single
unbroken egg which reminded her of a
time that the doc had stated he could
transfer his powers Angela consumed the
egg and went out
Poole to see if she'd gained his
abilities and then we cut to black yup
they got us it was an agonizing way to
end the show and even after a month
since its release we are no closer to
learning the truth if you've been
keeping up to date with the news on the
show then you may have seen earlier this
week that HBO officially said that they
were not moving forward with season two
while some outlets have said that the
show was canceled Damon Lindelof
actually said before the finale even
aired that he felt like he told the full
story and then he had no plans for a
second season
but why end it on such a big cliffhanger
well the original Watchmen graphic novel
it did end on a cliffhanger itself with
dr. Manhattan saying that nothing really
ends and Rorschach's journal being put
out into the public through the press as
for the show according to Lindelof the
clues are all there when talking to The
Hollywood Reporter the creator's said
the following in regards to the finale
this is not me saying what happens when
a foot hits the water
there are certainly two possible
outcomes but if you watch the entire
season again or if you look at the
poster for Watchmen that existed 15
weeks ago our intention is clear
that's why I'll say whilst you could go
either way
after personally revisiting the season
looking at the poster and weighing up
the clues there is one clear outcome
that is that Angela did get his powers
and had we not cut to black we would
have seen a walk on water now in order
to understand why this is set up in
Watchmen already you have to comprehend
one of the big themes of the property as
a whole that is inheritance the story
has always been about passing things on
and this is exemplified through the
majority of its characters night alt who
picked up the mantle after the first
incarnation Silk Spectre raised her
daughter in an image hooded justice went
on to have a grandchild who also became
a superhero the comedian was Lori's
father Rorschach inadvertently went on
to inspire the seventh Cavalry
Ozymandias made lady true lady true
literally forced her daughter to become
her own grandmother and so on and so
forth there's tons of examples and
pretty much every character left behind
a legacy that was taken up by someone
else except for dr. Manhattan who didn't
now if we are going off the themes then
there exists
a lot of weight there is to Angela
inheriting the characters powers and
nurse bringing everything full circle
before we get into the main evidence
that highlights that he was able to pass
on his powers we have to explain how dr.
manhattan's abilities actually work
Manhattan has a simultaneous view of all
moments within his lifetime he views
every single second that he existed in
at once he can see both his past present
and future
and because of this we can understand
that time is in fact cyclical the future
controls the past because in order for
the future to happen in the way that it
will the past has to and vice versa
it's a lot of time you I mean
wibbly-wobbly stuff but the fact that
dr. Manhattan gives Angela instructions
such as him saying that he needs to sear
on the pool and that the eggs are
important means that in the future he is
aware of the effect that they had thus
we can draw from this that dr. Manhattan
did not die because if he had he would
not be aware of the swimming pool having
importance as he was not present when
Angela attempted to step on it
again it's very confusing and mixed up
but this is one of the central rules of
the universe there also exists a lot of
dialogue too that backs up the fact that
the egg carried these abilities when we
are first introduced to this notion in
episode 8 and hatton creates the egg and
then states that through it he would be
able to pass on his powers but how does
he know that this would work well the
answer is because he already knows the
outcome as in the future he is
retroactive Lee seen that passing his
powers onto angela through this method
has worked she likely freed him after
the events of the show and thus he now
knows that he can pass his powers on
through the egg and so he tells her in
the past now why this is ham at home
even more it's because when discussing
the egg Angela asks the following if I
ate this egg could I walk on water
that's it
that's the entire question and it's also
how the show ends she flat-out asks if
she ate the egg if she could walk on
water thus the idea is planted in
Angela's head which would become key to
the final few shots of the season eggs
are massively important throughout the
series and we are even introduced to
Angela through them will Reeves pulls
one out of boiling hot water we see the
Clarkes drop
huge amount of them and throughout the
season there is clear attention drawn
towards them water too becomes symbolic
as it is used to create life and dr.
Manhattan states that it is important
that Angela sees the characters standing
on it he then goes off to make some crap
which seems out of character during the
life ending situation as in however he
only does this to point out the eggs
which Angela grabs and smashes she later
discovers these and thus him pointing
out the pool and the one unbroken egg
has a lot of meaning to it he drew
attention to both the eggs and himself
walking on water for a reason
now it's also during this moment that
another key thing comes into play that
is that dr. Manhattan realizes he loves
Angela when they first met he said there
was not a specific moment for him in
which you realize that they were in love
as all moments exists for him at once
however when he returns decade later he
does in fact say that this is the moment
he realizes that he loves the character
could this be him deeming her worthy
realizing that she is finally deserving
of his powers well personally I believe
that it does so in conclusion Angela
took the egg realized that she was able
to walk on water used her newfound gifts
to bring Manhattan back and thus he was
able to tell her in the past the
importance of it all it is the chicken
and egg situation that the doc describes
in episode 8 and is exemplified by
Angela informing her grandfather in the
past of Judd and so on this rule was set
up to show the outcomes for the
characters and thus once more the past
is the future as the future is the past
Manhattan engineered the entire thing in
order to bring himself back from the
brink of destruction by placing his
powers into the one person who would
have the desire to save him another key
indicator that Angela gains his
abilities is exemplified by the poster
as mentioned earlier Lindelof stated
that their intentions were clear and
once we revisit the poster it becomes
explicit what the outcome is angela is
clearly shown with a blue tint to a skin
similar to the one that dr. Manhattan
has and the creative team behind the
show are very clearly laying their cards
on the table here and staying that she
did indeed gain these abilities so to
weigh it all up the themes of
inheritance
the constant eggs throughout and hatton
pointing out specific things the dialog
choices and the poster I think you have
a pretty compelling argument that Angela
did inherit the abilities but what does
Regina King the actor behind Angela
think well in an interview with IGN she
said the following the way I perceived
it because I really fell in love with a
story between Angela and dr. Manhattan I
felt like when she saw that egg she
wasn't necessarily looking at it as this
opportunity to take on his powers so my
interpretation of it was she saw this as
one last chance that she could be close
to John that somehow this would bring
them back together or as crazy as it
sounds maybe there'd be one I believe
that this was a continuance of the love
story I'm just one of those people are
in love with love and I just felt like
it's amazing that in all of the
storytelling of pain and trauma and
anger that they were able to sneak an
ultimate love story I feel like for the
most part even though you see this woman
and anger going up into Nixon bill and
putting the guy in a trunk and all of
that I still feel like she's a very
responsible person he is a person that
inherited three children because of a
partner being killed during the white
night so I would guess that you would be
responsible with those powers so it does
look like qinger selfies the character
is being able to possess the abilities
to whilst we may never know I think that
is enough there to draw our own
conclusions and know it would be great
to get a second season that doesn't mean
we need one now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the ending and
whether you disagree or agree with my
conclusion comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and if you
want something else to watch it make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
first review of Black Widow it contains
big plot spoilers including who
taskmaster is the post-credits scene and
a lot more you can support the show by
subscribing to us and patreon and if you
want to come chat to us after the video
then join our discord server in the
description below or follow us on
twitter at definition whitey that's the
best way to keep up to date with
everything we do at heavy spoilers and
hopefully we see over there very soon
also just one let you know we're giving
away a free copy of dr. sleep to one
random subscriber and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of
is like the video subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
Watchmen in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February in the subtle be
shipped out from the enter forgets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]